and I wanted to mention two things
before we get started one I spent the
last few days with bucko the cat Mr
bocus and we traveled across country to
a stem cell Clinic that was able to
harvest some of his fat cells they
thought we didn't they didn't get enough
fat he called me today and told me your
cat's a rock star somehow out of six
grams of fat they got as many stem cells
out of what they could get out of 150
grams of fat from a dog and he was he
was shocked almost in shock at how met
how well bucko did
um thank you Bucko for for keeping
positive I don't know if there's some
sort of entanglement going on in your
cells over there doing well because
you're doing well over here or no no
it's it's all the people who have
watched and have prayed for Mr boat it
really cellular life is attuned to the
vibration of your soul so keep it up and
I I just want to say like I I
I have to wonder about that